sur la réforme des retraites ça fait
partie de l'ADN des républicains le
corps enfin le Conseil le conseil de
l'orientation de retraite dit que le
système de retraite est déficitaire donc
il y aura une mesure d'âge c'est
imparable avec l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie il y a deux choses
sur lequel effectivement auquel on tient
c'est la pénibilité et les carrières
longues et ça il faut en débattre vous
pouvez pas avoir je parlais tout à
l'heure quand j'étais je travaillais
dans ces entrepôts de fruits et légumes
à 14 ans moi j'ai commencé j'étais
déclaré de 16 ans à 22 ans j'ai été de
soignante de jour et de nuit j'ai
travaillé à l'hôpital et moi mais mes
collègues de l'époque à ce jour à ce
jour elle travaille encore je les vois
pas aller jusqu'à 67 ans 70 ans c'est un
métier
usant c'est un métier compliqué c'est un
métier où il manque toujours du
personnel d'ailleurs les 35 heures ont
totalement désorganisé l'hôpital et donc
moi j'ai le souvenir de ce travail là